today's vlog starts on a bittersweet
note
because i'm leaving and i'm going to
texas to shoot some really cool content
and to actually check out a bunch of
really dope okay where's the bitter part
let's go with the better part um
everything sounds really sweet so well
one of my friends over there uh he
opened like pretty much the disneyland
version of the gym okay and it's
freaking huge and there's like three
gyms in there that sounds fun it's a
sick clothing store
so the better part
the better part is i'm gonna meet
another friend who opened up a gummy
company and he's like a
multi-millionaire now
where's the bitter part dude
adam's gonna have a really fun trip
[Music]
just kidding
the little monkey dude is sleeping in
the back oh my god his head is all the
way tilted over
usually when he's sleeping he looks like
he's pretending he's like this
yeah my dad's like he fell asleep
well but it's bittersweet because this
was like the first weekend i had in a
long time and i was really looking
forward to spending some really cuny
time with the family especially to get
warm now there's this lake i wanted to
go to in vegas but i have to go check
out my two really cool friends new place
with a lot of like dope stuff six
storefronts sick gym big old company i
know they're gonna take me out because
they have lots of money so i'm gonna
show you a really good time
have fun
such a horrible time can you believe me
please don't have a lot of fun fine
thank you i love you so much
this is crazy for some reason it feels
like i haven't flown in a really really
long time
dude this is crazy the airport feels so
foreign i don't know what it is i used
to travel all the time right and i could
have sworn i traveled recently or maybe
i haven't even remember anymore or maybe
i've traveled but only by car in the
last two years so it feels really crazy
because like
i used to be so comfortable in the
airport i know exactly where all the
terminals are i know how to check in
like i could do with my eyes closed i
could probably be drunk off my ass
throwing up
puking and still figure everything out
but i was like wait am i supposed to go
check my back in first
uh do i need to like
pull this out i'm like so confused i'm
like wait don't i have like tsa
pre-check i forgot everything
yo this is crazy man
yep this is my view just walking forward
and all of this feels so
so foreign and strange to me
so we got little doggies
strange sound
all right baggage claim that's not me
cause i'm leaving
i'm looking for gay d55
all right that's where i'm going
all right so people definitely ain't
scared of travel no more
there's way more people at the airport
now
right so you know i was funny so i
rolled up to the tsa lady right and i'm
staring at her and staring at me
now staring at her like
and she's just staring at me and we
stared at each other for a good
20 30 seconds before she went like this
i'm like oh cause i have my mask on and
i didn't know so i'm just all happy like
cool
but i didn't get the memo that as soon
as you show up to the lady she needs to
check your face
with the id
which is just so funny
what's cool though is that everyone's
just as lost as me so as soon as
everyone got to the tsa like almost
every other tsa line was completely open
and the other ones were jam-packed shout
outs to the tsa worker that was there
though like he was helping people file
in so i just don't think anyone knows
the routine anymore so everyone's just
freaking out people not taking off their
shoes before they get on the airplane
people having laptops in the backpack
without taking them out there's just all
these like i think
things that when you used to travel on
the regular you remember like even for
someone like me i forgot all kinds of
stuff
and now i forgot where i was supposed to
go i gotta figure this out
[Music]
all right cool found it d55
i'm gonna make it
[Music]
that's cool everything's starting to
look a little bit more familiar
i've been here before but it ain't a
vegas airport without
slot machines
why don't i always get stuck with the
terminal that's way way way at the end
watch i don't even know if you can see
but that's 50 and i got to get all the
way down to 55 which is away from the
food
the two choices were either burgers or
pizza and
i had burgers for lunch
so pizza it is
so i can either be a good boy get that
cauliflower crust
or i could be a bad boy and get
pasta
garlic cream
fettuccine
what do you think i should get
all right curveball so i thought i was
gonna be stuck between pasta or
the pizza but i saw this the turkey club
and that actually looks really good i'm
not even trying to eat healthier it just
looked really good and refreshing
because probably because i had a big-ass
cheeseburger for lunch i just feel like
oily and gunky and just looking at the
salad and like all of that just looks
like crispy like
i was having a good ass time just eating
and chilling and just relaxing by myself
now i was like looking at the time i was
like nice 6 15 and i'm like oh [ __ ]
we're bored at 6 17. i have to get up
and run down and thank god i made it on
time and good thing for once i'm group
three
because usually you know when you're
like the later groups like oh man it's
gonna be a while before i sit down but
this time i'm actually glad that i'm in
the later groups so that they're
boarding groups one and two so i can
finally make it on the flight that have
been so funny i get to the airport like
an hour early and i miss my flight that
would be so ridiculous
just landed
it's 11 30 is about a two hour time
difference i believe
i walked by this bar and i was like
what barbecue in a re in a airport and
i'm like
because it's texas i completely forgot
that texas is all about barbecue so
hopefully
grab some barbecue tomorrow or the day
after tomorrow
i'm actually here to visit two friends
that have been crushing it in the
fitness space one of them not even in
fitness so one christian guzman
just opened up alpha land and it is like
a disneyland
of gyms i believe his it's a campus
first of all and on that campus there's
three gyms
uh resort cafeteria all that and then
max tuning he's been crushing it with
the sour strips like gummy candies
and he has his whole empire there so i'm
just there to check it out hang out with
them haven't seen them in a long time
but we're all like
uh ogs of like fitness youtube you know
so it's just so cool to see them
grow and blow up and have these amazing
companies so that's why i'm out here and
uh mainly to shoot
all of this content for the barber gate
channel
but i'm just vlogging it so you guys can
see the behind the scenes
of everything
oh
dude i thought there was a guy right
behind me that ad scared me i was like
who's that guy
nadeem
hey you look cute in this car dude
hurry up if i get a ticket
oh they get tickets on here like that
i don't know but i don't want to [ __ ] up
that's true
florida what the
what the heezy
how do you open this car
what
what
dude
i don't know how to use that car
how do you open this car
this car is crazy there you go
i don't know how to use this car dude
one two three
okay
all right this is the houston
downtown
looks nice
oh damn a stupid parking structure
all right so
i was trying to buy water
but they ran out i'm freaking thirsty
they just came off a three-hour flight
and i was gonna buy water at the airport
but it's also like 12 o'clock at night
now so nothing's open
so we devised a plan
where we're going pack this full of ice
and then maybe put the ice in the
microwave
or just drink tap water
but i also don't know how good the tap
in houston is i also don't wanna stomach
it you have to trade with all my friends
tomorrow
that should be enough water
do you have water in your room i have a
soda
that's your water huh no but i have i'll
take ice
you want to throw those cups up yes take
it from here
i'll fill it up
all right so i got the ice
now i'm looking for the microwave and
i'm like do we not have one
aha
oh wait is there ice in the i mean water
in the fridge
nope
but is styrofoam cups
are they microwave safe
dude i don't even know
should i just use this paper cup right
here yeah that's probably better
all right this is so stupid i have ice
and then i'm gonna put it in the
microwave
to make water
how long do i need to put in there for
a minute
[Music]
i guess we'll wait and see
all right guys moment of truth
it's warm and cold at the same time damn
one minute wasn't enough
all right
i just gotta give it another minute
[Music]
meanwhile unpack my bags
so one little cool trick i learned
you ever notice when you travel and
you're in hotels like your first day or
two you never really get good sleep
so if you end up only staying in a hotel
room like one or two days each time for
like let's say two or three or even a
whole month
you're gonna have like the worst
recovery the worst sleep
in your life and you're just gonna feel
so groggy and that's because there's a
protective mechanism in your brain when
you're in a new environment only half of
your brain shuts down so that you can
instantly wake up because uh your brain
doesn't
feel safe you know so it wants to be on
like half alert so that you're not in
deep sleep and then like predators come
so it's like a natural
instinct that goes on in your brain so
for me what i've realized is you i used
to just sleep naked
um like in hotel rooms
but then like let's say if i'm traveling
like i'm only going to be here for two
days
and so right when my body literally
feels comfortable i have to change
environments and
that's going to be horrible sleep
horrible recovery i'm still trying to
get strong you know and i want to feel
good the next day so my own little hack
that i did is i started bringing pajamas
like clothes that i'm really really
comfortable with that i'm like wearing
at home so when i sleep
it actually tricks my body into feeling
comfortable and i have been getting
pretty deep sleep actually
wearing pajamas on the road so you guys
might want to try that out
all right
i heard that
let's see if this works
i gotta wait two minutes oh it's all
water now don't tell me i gotta wait two
minutes every time i want water oh you
know what water's warm oh wait actually
it's cold
cold water coming out of the microwave
that all some of this ice in there
oh yeah
life of lux remember
life alert
damn look at that ice cold water i
haven't drank water
in three hours
and this looks absolutely delicious
cheers
[Music]
oh microwave water is pretty good
microwave hotel water
about to make some more
but on that note thank you guys so much
for following
my cuny day of travel
back in the hotel room by myself
tomorrow i have lots of cool things
planned so stay tuned goodnight
everybody